I also cheers so this is all so
horrifying Sears you have to dempster
know so I do damage to a night watch it
like this this whole thing goes awry so
he's right here dammit the lip of the so
I starfall him I actually send him up
and now what do I I get rocketed d
zoning characters for lawbreakers is an
interesting process you may think that
it begins with the design team and then
immediately moves to the art team but
that's not the case as our studio grew
we structured the development to create
deep multiplayer characters by focusing
on rapid gameplay iteration or
prototyping to make sure that we find
the fun in everything that we do and
play the game every single day and
maverick was the first character to
solidify that process this is her story
when bosque first started we had
character design ideas but we needed to
establish a process maverick was the
first character to set the stage for how
we develop characters now as she
established a system for characters to
include a call sign or name their role
in the battlefield and what faction they
belong to in the fiction our design team
establishes those gameplay needs first
and then the character creation process
begins we start out usually with just
trying to figure out what is fun it
sounds simple enough but you know what's
fun what gaps are we missing what holes
do we need filling in the game and we
realized we needed somebody a little
more in the air consistently so maverick
was a special character as a vertical
character it's one of our characters
that we really dug into into the
vertical space I mean but we've also
wanted to temper her with the idea that
she needed to be close she needed to be
up front and in your face so we gave her
this big gattling gun that drove her to
be closer to the fight which is why
she's a skirmisher the idea of coming
into the middle of a fight running in
hard recklessly without much armor
getting into the fight but also jetting
away really quickly so that's who she is
that's when I say maverick people have a
instant vision in their mind when we
talk about skirmisher skirmishers a play
style and because we're symmetric game
we want to make sure that players
regardless of which side they're playing
on whether it's lawbreakers understand
what the gameplay is to come from the
good role that they've selected right
and skirmisher comes with a play style
but they'll choose maverick maverick
represents the law but the faction
cheesin the Valkyries kind of temper
that personality they put her into a
space that dictates how may be good or
how evil she is or whether or not she
upholds the law or breaks the law
positive wire
i jus quad kill design and programming
must work as a team to bring characters
to the play test environment like I said
earlier you may think that the art team
receives the character description from
designing gets to work on the visuals
first right no that's not how it works
for us at this point the character goes
into prototyping with our gameplay
programmers who translate design into
actual gameplay simply put we want to
find the fun first once Dan and cliff
have sort of decided on the high level
concept for the character I take over
the process at that point and I'm
responsible for the design and the
implementation of the specific weapons
and abilities that make up that
character as well as coding the
underlying systems that all characters
share maverick is actually a really
interesting character story because
while she did change several times
during development I feel like maverick
is actually sort of foundational to what
the game has become when you first add
characters into a game like this the
game doesn't really exist yet and so the
characters can kind of become whatever
they whatever they want but at some
point when maverick comes into the game
in terms of how much mobility she's
bringing and her gravity manipulation it
really forced us to sort of re-evaluate
what the air other characters could do
and it really changed and defined what
the game was about prototyping is
actually really crazy prototyping is
essentially um you take a high-level
idea and you really don't know where
it's going to end up usually what I do
is paper design which is a one-page
overview of essentially ideas for what a
character could be and from that paper
design I start you know doing
implementations and trying them out in
the game one of the earlier versions of
maverick actually her all fire her
right-click was a shield that you could
bring up like this and then shoot your
Gatling gun at the same time and while
it is up now I look back and I'm like I
don't know what I was thinking I mean
you can see back in the day you know
we're such a small team gpb's have to
wear a lot of hats so I actually did all
the animations on this prototype and
that's why you can see this like woot
hang hand here where she's holding the
Gatling gun and this like white cylinder
that I was like oh this vaguely looks
like a vaguely looked like a Gatling gun
I'm gonna model it and buy and do my
best you know I think it was actually
one of the shortest-lived features we've
had in the game I think it survived
maybe one or two play tests so people
just essentially turd turtling behind
this shield and shooting people up and
it was it was terrible as atrocious
while some prototypes never see the
light of day our tried and true
characters are put into our daily play
test sessions which we take very
seriously at Bosque we play test from
beginning until end we play test every
day I think about three times a day on
average is what we're doing in the
beginning it's really just trying to
feel out the character to make sure it's
fun but then after we get it to Trammell
and after the art team arts it up and
makes it pretty the character comes back
to us and we need to make sure that
things like effects are reading
correctly you know do you understand
what's happening when you press the
qubit button do you understand what's
happening when e is pressed so we need
to make sure that everything after art
has come in services communication not
just the person who's actually doing the
actions but also from the enemies that
are receiving the actions because if you
get killed and you have no understanding
as to why you got killed or what
destroyed you it's just as frustrating
as not understanding why your abilities
don't work or your weapons don't work
the way you think they should be work
you throw a character into the play test
and you start finding out all the things
that are wrong with it and so it becomes
this this back-and-forth of gathering
feedback from people within the studio
and then making changes to adjust to
that feedback pretty much every day and
this just goes on and on until the
character is really polished and really
sings making maverick actually taught us
a lot of lessons about the process that
we use here and one of the things that
we do and one of the things we put a lot
of value on is delighting players with
things that they've never seen before
and doing gameplay that you don't see in
other games something a lot of other
games tend to do with their class design
is sort of just straight-up copy classes
or mechanics that exist in other games
but we placed a huge value on things
that people haven't seen and so we just
don't do that we spend the extra time in
the extra effort to make sure that even
if we start with something that is for
earlier that we guide it to a place
that's unique how did you play a life
domination remembered story is special
because her abilities her weapons and
her characterization all developed as
bosque matured as a studio we're going
to be doing more of these dev Diaries in
the future and we want to hear what you
want to see from the behind the scenes
process at Bosque so please let us know
follow us on twitter at law breakers and
at Bosque and way in from everybody at
the studio thanks for watching